next we got another uncle Jeff - Jeff's
yep this is from Salt Lake this uncle
Jeff well goddamn Jeff looks like I've
met this guy before I mean him have the
same barber apparently that can be a
father look that could be me look at the
second pitch is he the second one oh wow
yeah he looks very similar
this guy is swagtastic look at his
outfit it's kind of this guy's this
guy's dope I wish she was my Uncle Dan
that guy's a straight-up swag dragging
on with that baby that matches that
shirt I know this is what is this rip
that's so fun yeah this is freaking trip
daddy baby that this uncle's not messing
around
yeah sure that is you is it yeah he's
enough yeah I don't like your sinister
smile holding that kid though I'd say
that right now
that ain't a sinister smile that's a
swag smile Rick no he's swagged out on
the right look at him taking a kid yeah
this is like trying to meet a lady you
take a little law the Bichon to the park
or whatever he shine that baby may be
shot I'll tell you that much right now
I know a bichon yeah be shunned yeah
that ain't him that ain't him tanner
[Laughter]
that's Chapman I bet this dude could
dance I'll tell you that much oh yeah
you're one white guy in the band that
doesn't dance with the stick you know
what I'm talking yeah that's it yeah
Wesley you know he went to a black
college yeah no he went to a black hole
he went to Grambling State Ted's a
Howard Dwight Howard College University
where he was a hair salon probably know
how are you don't learn that in the
white neighborhood uncle we've had on
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]